this was a final spectacular farewell to
tokyo and these paralympics but like
most of the action there was nobody
there to witness it in person
boccia gold medalist david smith was
chosen as great britain's flag bearer
for the closing ceremony
the pandemic brought many hurdles for
the organizers and athletes but
overcoming challenges is second nature
when you're a paralympian a lot of our
paralympic athletes have underlying
health conditions that mean that they've
had more severe um isolation and for
much longer periods and they've had to
make really hard decisions about not
seeing family not seeing friends not not
having the sort of cares that they would
normally have through that time
so they faced um just immense challenges
that that a few years ago when we sort
of said goodbye to rio and look forward
to tokyo we had no idea this was around
the corner so
to have got through all that to still
have the same desire the same passion
the same drive the same ambitions for
tokyo is truly exceptional paralympics
gb finished second in the overall table
behind china with 124 medals across 18
of the 19 sports they competed in
41 of them were gold
some more medals than london 2012 but
fewer than rio in 2016. hugely proud i'm
smiling um behind this mask even if you
can't see me
it's been a brilliant team for
performance over the 12 days of
competition
and you know we've rewritten the history
books as a team by meddling in more
sports than any other nation has ever
achieved at a paralympic games which is
hugely satisfying these games saw
sarah's story become britain's greatest
ever paralympian with her 17th gold
medal
they also showcased new young talent
like swimmers maisie summers newton and
rhys dunn to name just two
london 2012 is credited with being a
game changer for the paralympic movement
in this country
the focus now will shift towards paris
in 2024 and the hope will be for more
medals more glory and more fans there to
see it and the brady sky news